[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the first
episode of Caring Hearts and open minds
I'm your host D and today we're diving
into a topic that affects us all in one
way or another which is mental health
it's a subject that unfortunately still
carries a lot of stigma and
misunderstanding but through open
conversations and spreading awareness we
can help break the silence surrounding
mental health to begin let's talk about
the importance of mental health
awareness why is it crucial for
individuals communities and society as a
whole mental health awareness is the
foundation of a healthier society when
we're aware of mental health issues and
understand what that they're common we
can reduce stigma and encourage people
to seek help this can lead to early
intervention better support systems and
overall improved well-being for everyone
mental health is just as important
important as physical health and we need
to treat it as such now let's discuss
some common misconceptions about mental
health what are some of the myths that
need to be
dispelled one prevalent myth is that
people with mental health issues are
just seeking attention in reality they
are often struggling with uh real
complex and sometimes invisible battles
another myth is that mental health
mental health issues are a sign of
weakness which they are not mental
health is influenced by a variety of
factors many of which are Beyond a
person's control these myths can lead to
shame and prevent people from seeking
help when they need
it breaking down the these
misconceptions is crucial for fostering
understanding and empathy now what can
individuals and communities do to
promote mental health awareness there
are several ways to promote mental
health awareness first we need to start
open conversations about mental health
share your own experiences if you feel
comfortable or simply listen and support
others when they share education is also
vital learn about the various mental
health conditions their symptoms and
treatment options finally reduce stigma
uh by treating mental health issues with
the same empathy and compassion as you
would uh with uh physical health
issues now let's address self-care and
mental health maintenance what are some
practical tips for our listeners to take
of their own mental
health self-care is essential it's not
just bubble bath and spa days even
though those can be part of it self-care
is a crucial aspect of maintaining good
mental health it involves a set of
intentional activities and practices
that individuals undertake to support
their own uh well-being reduce stress
and enhance their overall quality of
life uh now we're going to elaborate on
self-care and provide more practical
tips for incorporating it into your
daily routine set boundaries
establishing clear boundaries is
essential for maintaining a healthy
balance in your life learn to say no
when you need to and don't overcommit
yourself this not only reduces stress
but also allows you to allocate time for
self-care mindfulness and meditation
mindfulness practices and meditation
help you stay present and reduce anxiety
and improve your overall mental
well-being
dedicate a few few minutes each day to
meditate or engage in deep breathing
exercises physical activity regular
exercise is a poent tool for managing
stress and boosting mood find the
physical activity you enjoy whether it's
jogging yoga dancing or simply going for
a walk in
nature nutrition eating a balanced diet
rich in Fruit fruits vegetables and
whole grains provides your body and mind
with the necessary nutrients for optimal
function avoid excess exessive caffeine
and sugar as they can lead to energy
crashes and moon swings adequate sleep
prioritize quality sleep create a sleep
friendly environment and establish a
consistent sleep schedule lack of sleep
can significantly impact your mental
health engage in activities you're
passionate about whether it's painting
reading cooking or playing a musical
instrument pursuing Hobbies provides a
sense of accomplish accomplishment and
relaxation soal connections nurturing
relationships with family and friends is
vital spending time with loved ones can
provide emotional support reduce
loneliness and offer a sense of
belonging digital detox limit screen
time and take breaks from social media
and Technology Conant exposure to
screens can lead to Stress and
Anxiety journaling writing down your
thoughts and feelings can be a
therapeutic practice it helps you
process emotions and gain clarity about
your mental uh State seeking
professional heal if you're struggling
with your mental health don't hesitate
to reach out to a mental health
professional they can provide guidance
and strategies to uh tailor to your
specific needs hydration stay hydrated
by drinking an adequate amount of water
dehydration can affect your mood and
cogni cognitive function spending time
in nature nature has a calming effect on
the Mind SP uh spending time in natural
surroundings whether it's a park a
forest or a garden can help reduce
stress and improv
mood also regularly Express gratitude
for the positive as uh aspects of your
life this can shift your focus from
negativity to positivity and improve
your mental
Outlook engage in self-compassion treat
yourself with the same kindness and
understanding that you'd offer to a
friend be patient with yourself during
challenging
times try relaxation techniques explore
relaxation techniques like progressive
muscle relaxation aroma therapy or a
warm back path to unmind and
distress Recreation and laughter engage
in recre recreational activities and
find reasons to laugh laughter is an
excellent stress reliever remember
selfcare is not a one-sized fits-all
concept it's about finding what works
best for you and incorporating this
practices into your daily routine as we
come to the end of this episode it's
important to reflect on the profound
Journey we've undertaken today mental
health awareness is is not just an
abstract concept it's a living breathing
movement that touches the lives of
millions in our conversation we've Del
deep into the significance of mental
health awareness for both individuals uh
and society as a
whole we've exposed the myths and
misconceptions that have held back Pro
progress for far too long and we've
explored ways in which we can
collectively uh promote mental health
awareness uh but what truly stands out
in in our conversation is the
transformative power of self-care is the
anchor in the storm the compass when
we're lost and the sanctuary in the
midst of chaos self-care is an act of
self-love and um it's a reminder that
our wellbeing is precious and deserving
of uh care and attention mental health
awareness is not just a month-long
campaign it's an ongoing
effort uh and together we can make a
difference in the lives of uh so many by
breaking the silence on Mental Health to
our listeners remember that mental
health is an integral part of your
overall well-being let's keep the
conversation going and continue to
support one another if you have any
questions or suggestions for future
episodes feel free to reach out to us
until next time take care be well and
don't forget to always stay
positive
[Music]